hey glamour i'm tina chen craig founder
of ubeauty so excited to be here with
you today
this is my five minute fast polished
makeup look
i start with ella lou's 24 karat gold
eye treatment i keep this in the fridge
i like to keep a lot of things in the
fridge you just
dab it in
also gives you a little bit of that glow
from the 24 karat gold i'm obsessed with
this i shake it up
ilia
this is a tinted
skin tint spf 40 spf sorry
it's a skin tint i just dot
dot
try not to touch her i don't want to
contaminate but my skin is clean then i
go in there with jenny patinkin i love
this makeup sponge
once it's blended in i go in because
it's not a heavy coverage it's so light
then i grab my
jones road beauty i live by these face
sticks i go between number five to
number eight five being the lightest so
five goes
right under the eye because i like to be
lighter and here's my trick i learned
this on tik tok
pull it out and then i do this
and then anywhere you have little spots
which i do
that's actually a mole
and then i blend it in then i also take
the five and go right under my brows
and then for my brows
a quick brow this is charlotte tilbury's
brow lift
and it's dual ended i love this one
because it's angled and what's great
about the charlotte tilbury is
it's refillable and i'm using a natural
brown it's called natural brown
another jones road product this is the
miracle bomb and dusty rose
just to give a very
healthy glow this is gucci westman
westman italia lip oil
that just launched this is a drugstore
air volume l'oreal
this is good okay i think that was five
minutes even with my gibber jabbering
my fast polished face
before i shower
i give myself a rigorous brushing with
joanna check's
body brush
and she says to always go up
and inwards towards your heart
so not only is this great for skin
health
cellular
regeneration
exfoliation but
great for blood circulation so you want
to go towards the heart i always wear
sunscreen and so
to remove the sunscreen or any makeup i
use a cleansing oil this is like my
makeup remover stuff this is a very
gentle from tula probiotic cleansing oil
after i wash with my old cleanser i go
in there with any gentle gel cleanser i
do like this one from is clinical i get
the big size this is a gentle gel
complex
and it just really deep cleans this one
bottle uv resurfacing compound will
replace
six to eight other products in your
routine so after you cleanse there was
always this confusion when do i use my
retinols when do i use my vitamin c when
do i use my lactic acid multi-hydroxy
acid glycolic acids
antioxidants um peptide i mean so much
confusion right so this takes all the
guesswork out now the body compound we
have is the sculpt arm compound so i
like to go in there with my resurfacing
compound first
join a check taught me that because it's
gonna exfoliate the skin prep it for the
skull the sculpt is my dream product
cream our super hydrator
is the most luxurious and intuitive
amazing moisturizer you'll ever use
not only is it i like to give myself two
to three pumps
is it a luxuriously rich cream base with
squalane and shea butter that allows
your skin to be protected with this
moisture barrier i use a couple of
different sunscreens depending on
my mood this is super goop unseen it's a
40 which i really like because it's
invisible
and then i also love the clay depot 50
this is like heavy duty if i'm gonna be
out in the sun
[Music]
my top three skin care do's and don'ts
okay first let's be positive let's do's
do
use
a
water filter do your research
and find smart strategic products that
really work
don't follow skincare trends that you
see on social media
don't
pick at your face don't wash your
face
with scalding hot water
my hot hair must-haves starts with the
goop detox this is a himalayan salt
scalp scrub shampoo it's a it's an
experience like no other gwen paltrow
told me i'd become obsessed with it and
she's right okay my favorite fragrance
that is the scent of me
if i tell you you're gonna smell like me
but it's okay i like to share i like to
layer
my elise 41 from the labo
with my kai gardenia oil my biggest
beauty indulgences have to be my facial
treatments i love joanna check facials i
don't even think of that as indulgent i
feel like that is a necessity of life my
best advice to aspiring beauty
entrepreneurs
is learning that pushing and persevering
is different from
never giving up i never say never give
up because
i feel like if it's the wrong thing
you should pivot right so instead i say
push and persevere i read that somewhere
years ago and i just thought that was so
incredibly smart
and you can push through the hard times
you can persevere through the rough
patches that was so much fun thank you
glamour i love being in your beauty spy
hopefully next time we can do this in
person in london
with a cocktail or two
bye